[Applause]
so funny we haven't seen each other
since you were my manager yes he was my
manager my Christmas special really
Clarkson yeah I was so nervous I told
you the backstage but I know I'm not an
actor so I was and you're so funny and I
was so nervous I was so sweaty you were
amazing you're just a honestly did the
special to meet you and you're just so
nice and so cool you said yes it was it
was so and I actually got to like
reference we did a scene together where
I think I reference walk away like you
know I'm just arguing with you in
character as a man I'm just gonna walk
[Laughter]
oh wait no he knows the song you know
everybody always is like I'm such a fan
yeah that one song it was great yeah no
but congrats though you just turned 50
right I just
I know I know I don't look it I get it
they say they say black don't crack well
asian don't raisin that's what they say
that's on my new album and I'm angry
about it because I'm not horrible years
away from 40 man tell me you know it
gets it's better right it gets cool
right you forty it's gonna be awesome
right are you once you turn 50 there are
you the guy on the the law and yelling
at children are you that guy well how
does that happen I'm more the guy who
just doesn't care anymore so that hit me
about 16 not literally you know you
don't care where I mean I know I'm
wearing this suit now I'm looking fine
but you know you don't care where
everything I wear is like gap shirt gap
genes gap jacket it's comfortable I'm
not even kidding this is like literally
what I wore to work these are I don't
know if the camera can get this right
here these are first of all great point
thank you these are these are Kirkland
brand socks
not a sponsor just got a sponsor women
size 6
just it's the only thing that lives and
breathes on mine oh yeah and my foot
toes yep
well congrats on the season 3 the mass
singer I was telling thank you thank you
huge fans of the show they totally guess
before y'all do they're credible at it
so what's new this year it is really
well first of all it is just such an
honor to be a part of an amazing family
show that it's cool you know families
love it and it's like my kids love it
Alexa and Zoe they love it it's so fun
to bring the family together watch it
and this season is just bigger and
better like the producers god bless them
they just find new ways to reinvent
themselves every year but the the talent
pool is deeper there they're just more
surprising reveals it really has evolved
the show has just gotten better as a as
it's gone along and and you know I'm
invested into it as a fan even if I
wasn't on the show I just I just love
it's a it's like America's guessing game
and it's just I love a game I'm not as
good my sister nails it every really yes
I mean you're looking a guy this you
never got a guess right yeah in three
years on a singer but you have another
project that's actually pretty amazing
um Women's Cancer Research Fund right
how did you get started in this thank
you I'm hosting a benefit on February
27th for the Breast Cancer Research Fund
and it's called an unforgettable night
and it is it's a fundraiser for research
for breast cancer my wife she's a breast
cancer survivor and yes you know it's an
honor to work with that organization and
other this we're actually honoring with
Renee Zellweger for her contributions to
breast cancer research it's an amazing
night I was I was there last year and
the amount of money we raise was was
just record amounts and everything it it
is wonderful that everybody we're all
using our efforts to ya the spotlight
and being a former physician you know
just knowing where this money goes and
advances in like specific receptor
therapy it can it can make all the side
effects from chemo very tolerable so
it's there's a lot of excitement you
know in the forefront of it and I know
it affects you personally and your wife
but yeah I feel like cancer hits home
with everyone if it's not directly its
indirectly everybody knows there's
cancer or know someone who has been
affected by cancer you're doing these
benefits it's important everybody
stepping up and doing that it's
important just to remind ourselves that
you know we are all cut from the same
cloth and now you know we you know if we
can do whatever we can to help and heal
each other yeah that's a good raise
money alleviate things yeah I agree with
you so what can people what can we do to
help like how can people help well you
can go to the website I believe it's
called w CR F cure org and I believe it
and you can and I'll put it on my social
media as well to help contribute and but
just the fact that you know thank you
for letting me even talk about it right
now it says we have it's a big deal to
me so thank you it's a big tilt to us
here to we've had actually at several
stories and several different
organizations on the show so far like
because it's important it's important to
eradicate it it's important to get there
and get to a cure yes absolutely all
forms of cancer yes absolutely I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my youtube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop
yep still here not going anywhere I see
you don't walk away from this